I'm a professor
involved with EECS.
And I [INAUDIBLE] 6.UAR I have
been a professor for 16 years
at MIT and taught 6.UAR for
the last two years or less--
maybe 18 months.
So I'm assuming you guys are
junior and senior students,
correct?
Actually, maybe you are
junior and sophomore, correct?
So we are here to tell you a
bit about the SuperUROP class.
So before I tell
you about SuperUROP,
I actually want
to hear from you.
What is SuperUROP?
What do you guys
know about SuperUROP?
Anyone?
Come on.
It's like a year-long
[INAUDIBLE]..
It's year-long.
What else?
I mean, guys, you are
here for some reason,
other than the pizza.
We understand pizza is
very important, but I mean,
you have to know something.
Come on.
You have to do a [INAUDIBLE]
presentations [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, so during
the class, you have
to present a poster at some
point, and also write a paper.
What else?
Why are you
interested, actually?
Yeah.
You got to continue
doing more research?
Oh, you do research.
That's cool, yeah.
OK, what else?
Why did you guys
come to this session,
other than the free pizza?
We're supposed to get
paid, like, $25 an hour?
Oh, payments, right.
Important.
To get paid for research.
Where else do you get
the class that pays you?
What else?
OK.
Are you just shy?
MIT students are not shy.
Satisfy the communication
requirements.
It satisfies the
communication requirements.
That's correct.
Anything else you guys
know about the class?
Yes?
I want to learn.
OK, great.
Know nothing.
Wants to learn.
OK, so let me tell
you about the class.
So SuperUROP class
has two components.
One of them is research.
So you can think of
this as two pillars.
To some extent, they
are not very connected
as much as other
classes where you
have components of other classes
that are very mixed together.
So in a sense, that
is one component,
which is your research.
So if you guys
decide to join 6.UAR,
then each one of you will
be associated with a faculty
professor and a mentor--
maybe a graduate
student or postdoc--
and you will be working
on a research project
within that group of
people, in their lab.
And that would be
the research section
of this SuperUROP class.
And then, in addition
to do research,
that is the class itself.
There are the lectures
and the recitations.
And those are more focused on
how you present your research.
So you are doing the research
in the lab with your professor
and mentor, and then
you go to the class,
you hear from professors
about their research.
So every lecture,
there are people,
like professors and
people from the industry,
that come and tell you
about their research.
And then, in the recitation
and some of the lectures,
we also talk about how you
can present to all research,
whether that presentation
is through posters
or through academic
papers that you write.
And hopefully, by the
end, you can submit
to a workshop or conference.
So these are the two components.
Now, of course, it is also
different from other classes
at MIT in the sense that
it is a two semester class.
So each semester,
you get six units.
So in the fall semester,
you get the first six unit,
and then you complete the
six other units in the spring
for total of 12 units of class.
Now, those 12 units--
so people, when
they hear six units,
they expect very
lightweight class.
But actually, the one thing
that you have to keep in mind
is that the six units
of class are actually
for the class-- are for the
time you spend in the lectures
and on the assignments
in the class.
And that is the workload.
It's six units of class.
But then, you are expected
to spend 10 hours per week
on your research.
And that's what
you are paid for.
That's where the
money comes from.
OK?
So keep in mind
these two things.
So research-- 10 hours per week
doing your research project
with your professor and mentor.
And then, in class,
you are planning
how to guide and
present your research,
whether in the fall
semester-- typically, we
work on the poster.
In the spring, we
work on a paper.
And that has its own set
of assignment associated.
Those are six units, but the
money is for the research,
and together, that is a class.
OK?
Now let me tell you a bit
about the research part.
So as I said, each one of you
would be working with someone,
like a professor at MIT.
Many of you probably
are EECS students,
and perhaps you are going
to work with some professor
here, in EECS.
Actually, who among
you is not in EECS?
Can you raise your hand?
OK, yeah.
So we have, in the
class, some people
from another part of
the engineering school.
And for you guys,
you also are going
to have a mentor and
professor that you are working
with in your department.
And these are some
example projects.
So here, you see some people
working on nanomaterials,
some people working on
circuits, some people working
on robots, many people working
on AI problems and machine
learning.
It's your favorite project.
You get to pick, and you
spend the semester on it.
And at the end of each semester,
you present your research.
So there is a showcase
where you prepare a poster,
and you stand there,
and we invite people
from the industry, we
invite the faculty, and also
your fellow students.
And everyone is there,
mingling, and we have food,
and it's a very nice event.
But also, you get to tell
people about your research,
based on what you learned
throughout the semester.
So that is one showcase at the
end of the fall, one showcase
at the end of this spring.
Now, as I mentioned, the
research part has up to $3,000
if you spent 10 hours
per week in the lab.
And that's $3,000 per
semester, so total of $6,000.
And in addition to that,
basically, as I said,
the 10 hours on the
research, that is not like--
you can't count the time
in the class and the time
on assignment for the class.
That is just an
hour for research.
Now, for students who are from--
so there are many departments
in the engineering school,
and my guess of the people
who raised their hand
and said they are
not part of EECS,
as many of those departments
are already participating
departments in the class.
But if your department is not a
participating department, which
means that it did
not donate money
to support their students,
then you can actually either
talk to your department
about the support,
or you can take the
class just as if it's
like a more formal UROP class.
So you can get those
credits, the academic unit.
But then, if you are not from
the supporting departments,
then, basically, we cannot
pay you in the class.
OK, so what are
the deliverables?
So in the fall
term, as I said-- so
the deliverable is the class.
First, attendance is mandatory.
I'm sorry.
But it's like we invite faculty
and professors here in EECS.
We invite people
from the industry.
So it is very important that
you actually show up to classes.
And during the class,
we ask a question
about the lecture, about
whatever those people have
presented, by the
end of the class.
And you enter the
answer online, and that
will be your attendance.
So in addition to classes--
the class is one hour per week--
and that is also one hour of
recitation every other week.
And there is about 15
minutes every other week
just checking in with
your TA, making sure
that everything is going right,
and if you have problems,
you can talk to your TAs.
They can give you, also,
feedback about your research,
in general.
And at the end of the fall
term, you prepare a poster,
and then you
present that poster.
Now, for the spring, it's
very, very similar to the fall,
except that instead
of for poster,
now you are working
on a 10 page paper
that you finish by the end
of the spring semester.
And you still go and
update your poster,
because now you
have more results,
and you present
your poster again
at the end of the
spring semester,
but now was full fledged
results and understanding
of your problem.
And many people ask
the question, OK,
so what is a grade that I get
by the end of the fall term?
But that's not the right
way to think about it.
You don't really get to grade
at the end of the fall term.
So it is a two term class.
So think about at the
end of the fall term.
It's like you're
finishing your midterm.
So you can know whether you
did well or not as well,
but you don't really have
a grade at that point.
It is one class that extends
across the fall and the spring,
and you're really get
your grade, whatever that
is, at the end of this spring.
OK?
You don't get any units if
you don't finish [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
So it's one class.
So again, think about it exactly
as at the end of the fall,
it's kind of like you
finish your midterm.
If you drop the
class at that point,
you don't get any
units from the class.
So also, there was a
particular opportunity
from a particular donor who
saw that MIT students  don't get
interested enough in
humanities, and he
wanted to promote the
connection between humanities
and engineering.
So he donated for
people who are to pay
for projects that combine
engineering with humanities.
So if you are
interested in that,
you can apply for
those projects.
OK, so also, you
get a certificate.
So you get a nice
piece of paper.
It's a certificate, and you
pass your SuperUROP class,
and we have a celebration.
I'll bring cookies and
food and all that stuff.
We take pictures.
OK, so I'm going to
stop a bit here and ask
whether you have any questions.
Yes?
How does [INAUDIBLE] work?
OK, so online, there is a site
that has proposals or project
descriptions by professors
in various departments
in the School of Engineering.
And you can go there and
look at those proposals,
talk to the PI, talk
to the professor,
and see whether it's
a good match for you.
And then at the
end, you are asked,
based on understanding
of that project
and understanding what
you talked to the faculty,
write a short proposal that--
I'm going to do this project.
This is my proposal for the
work that I'm going to do here.
And I'm going to tell you
the exact deadline for that.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, that's possible.
Yeah.
Yes.
Can you let us, if we have
an existing UROP [INAUDIBLE]
because they're
just [INAUDIBLE]??
Yeah, you can do it, but we
ask that the work that you do
for SuperUROP is new research.
So you can extend your project
and do the next step with it,
and that would be
your SuperUROP,
but we don't accept that-- oh,
I did this UROP before, and here
is my paper.
Here's all the work that I did.
Now, pay me $6,000.
That doesn't work.
Other questions?
Yes?
For this, is it that you
apply to this program
and then you look for a
project to work on within it?
Or you apply for a project?
To make things a bit
easier for you guys,
we ask the professors to
upload projects on the site.
And you can go and
look at those projects
and see whether you are
interested in any of them,
talk to the professor, and see
whether you have a good match.
But also, as your friend
here said, basically,
if you have already
a project and you
have a faculty who is
interested in mentoring you
as you are doing this
project, that's fine, as well.
Yeah?
Does your credit have to have an
intersection with [INAUDIBLE]??
It has to have intersection
with engineering,
but this is under the
School of Engineering.
There are-- I think most of
the departments in the School
of the engineering are
supporting departments,
but it doesn't have
to be course 6.0.
So as long as it has an
engineering component.
So if it's an [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah.
Yeah, of course it's possible.
So you said [INAUDIBLE]
proposals for our project
after the deadline.
[INAUDIBLE] if you want to
work on the same project,
[INAUDIBLE] research
[INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, it is OK.
But keep in mind
that, basically, you
have to take responsibility.
So if you change things
later in the term,
or after some deadlines,
we are flexible,
but it means that
you have to ramp up
in a shorter period of time.
So as long as you
are responsible
and you know that you
can do that, no problem.
OK, so I'll take more questions.
But let me just ask you guys--
so why should you do 6.UAR?
Why should you do SuperUROP?
Hm?
There are many classes at MIT.
Many of them that
are very interesting.
Why should you do SuperUROP?
Grad school.
OK, why SuperUROP could
be useful for grad school?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, I mean basically,
research is essential
if you want to go
to grad school.
In fact, I mean, at
this stage, people
expect that you have some
publication or at least
some submission.
So to go to--
again don't get scare---
I'm just seeing like,
the faces are flashing.
But I mean, basically, the
more research background
you have as you apply for grad
school, the better position
you are in to get accepted
and to get the interest,
if it is a good faculty
in that department.
Why else?
Hm?
Why should you do this?
Yes?
Invent.
This is like--
I was an MIT student, actually.
I didn't do my undergrad here.
I did my grad school here.
And I remember, I when I
was a graduate student,
I mean, basically, MIT students
would not stop talking.
Just ask questions that
are, in many cases,
even random questions.
Just keep talking.
Now, you guys are so shy.
Just like-- a question.
Nobody asking any questions.
Yes?
I think it's a chance
to pursue [INAUDIBLE]..
A chance to pursue--
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, so actually, honestly,
the most important reason
to do this is to try actual
research, particularly if you
are passionate about something--
like some particular field
of research-- to try to
get into understanding it.
So just to give you an
example, so you guys--
I mean, I don't know--
how many of you have been
engaged in research so far?
OK, so that's good.
Like a reasonable
percentage of you.
But if you think
about it, I mean, MIT,
what is so special about MIT?
I mean, the classes are
great, but really, this
is a research university.
This is the place where the
best and most interesting
research in engineering happens.
And if you are spending four
years here and graduating
with a degree, whether you
are going to grad school,
or going to the industry, or
starting your own company--
whatever it is-- if you
haven't done research
and haven't experienced it,
then you missed the whole point.
You missed the best thing here.
Yeah, you've got the classes.
But that's really
not the whole story.
That's a very, very
small part of the story.
It's like going to Paris and
not seeing the Eiffel Tower,
for example.
It's like everyone's
going to ask you about it.
So it is an opportunity to
get exposed to research.
Some people really
love it after that,
and they decide they want
to go to grad school,
and they want to
become researchers.
Very few people discover,
no, this is not for me.
But at least you tried it.
So the most important reason
is actually to do research.
What else do you get
by taking this class?
Yes?
Half a question, half
make sure you can do it.
it gives you more
experience with what
you can get out of a UROP--
like a normal UROP--
perhaps you're
not guaranteed that you're
going to get experience out
of it in terms of posters,
submissions, writing a paper,
whereas this would be a more
guaranteed and fast-tracked
route?
Exactly.
So in a sense, for people
who did UROP and had
like a very structured and
organized UROP experience,
you got a lot of the
experience with research.
But what the class
allows you to do
is to do it in a
more systematic way.
And for people who haven't
done it, to actually do it.
But basically, because not
only are you doing research,
you are also presenting
that research as like--
OK, tell me about your research.
Prepare a poster
about your research.
Talk to me about your research.
Then you are actually learning
as a whole process of doing
the research, while you
are doing that in the lab,
but also, how do you
present your research?
How do you eventually get a
technical paper, hopefully,
out of it?
And be an effective
researcher, both in terms
of doing the actual work
and communicating it
to other people.
And being paid for it.
OK, other reasons to do it?
How about the
communication requirements?
How many of you have this
communication requirement?
So you get done with it.
So these are a few
reasons, right?
Always, in the feedback, people
are happy about the money.
But I don't think that's
the most important reason.
The most important reason
is the research and being
exposed to the research.
That's the one thing
that you should not
miss after four years at MIT.
And you get your
CI-M requirement.
So other things about
the class that are cool
is, like, it's really even cool
for me as professor at MIT.
So every lecture, we
invite one to two speakers.
And those people
are MIT faculty.
So imagine, those people
are typically paid--
I don't know-- humongous
amounts of money
to come and give a
lecture somewhere.
But they come and give you a--
20 of them come to
one of those class
to tell you about
their research,
what they are doing.
And it is really a
great opportunity
that doesn't happen otherwise.
And you get to see research
across the whole broad spectrum
of engineering, from machine
learning, to computer vision,
to NLP, to circuits,
to computer systems,
to networks, to, sometimes,
people in material sciences,
in biology, or bioengineering,
digital health.
It's a whole broad spectrum.
And yeah, you are in
the lab doing one thing,
focusing on your problem
and your project,
but it gives you
perspective, and that's
across all of these
fields and areas.
And that's really--
I mean, as you get
to experience it,
it actually is a
great experience,
if you are interested.
I mean, you are
all at MIT, you I
assume you are interested
in science and engineering.
OK so where to learn
more about the SuperUROP.
So you can go to
superurop.mit.edu.
And if you want to
apply, then you apply
at superurop-apply.mit.edu,
and this is the contact email.
I mean, if you go
to the site, you'll
find all the email
and the information.
But the other thing
that I want to end with
is some of the deadlines,
so that all of you
are aware of them.
So April 3-- so as we said,
basically, go on the website,
try to check for the
projects that are available.
And you are also free to try
to create your own project, as
long as you find
some professor who
is willing to
supervise that project.
So April 3 is deadline of having
intent and saying that you
want to join the SuperUROP.
April 27 is the deadline
for submitting a proposal.
So, as we said, you go and
talk to that professor,
you understand the
project better,
and then you submit
about one page
of description of that project.
Typically, we ask you to
have some figures just
to show that you have some
understanding of the project
that you're going to work on.
And in June, we announce
the funding and who
is going to be in the class.
Do you want to add something?
So that says include
that are recommendations
for primary supervisor.
You don't have to include it.
You have to ask your supervisor
to upload it independently.
Is that for recommendation,
or just that
they accept a student
to work with them.
They say, I'm enthusiastic
about supervising this student.
I believe they will be
successful in the project they
have proposed.
Yeah, so it's not like
they have to write
a full letter of
recommendation, just
that they are
saying that they are
enthusiastic to work with you
and they have talked to you.
So that's the last slide I have.
I can answer
two more questions.
Yes?
How does the
application review work?
Who reviews the application?
What are the chances
of getting in?
So the chances are very high.
Unless we believe that,
for example, your GPA--
if a person's GPA is very
low and we think that they
are taking too many classes.
Or the GPA might
be high, but they
are taking too many classes,
they don't have time
to spend 10 hours
a week in the lab,
then those cases are the ones
that get rejected, mostly.
Most people get accepted.
So as long as you are
doing reasonably well,
you are not
overloading yourself,
we think that you have a
reasonable chance of success
succeeding in the class,
then you get accepted.
And the advisor has to, of
course, agree to supervise you.
Who's reviewing
the applications?
This staff.
The SuperUROP staff.
So the staff is a collection
of faculty, research,
senior research staff, and TAs.
So if you were to
not have funding,
and you were doing this for
credit, how would credit work?
Would it just be 10 hours
of credit, like a UROP,
and then it would be
graded or ungraded?
So it would be like UROp.
And Dorothy has been
with the class for--
I don't know-- since it
started in 2012, so she has--
I didn't hear the question.
So if the SuperUROP
is for a credit,
would it be 10 hours of
graded, ungraded credit,
[INAUDIBLE]?
Pass/fail.
Yes?
Should that transcript-- does
it need to be an official one,
or can you just take a
screenshot of the grade report?
Can she take a screenshot
of the transcript?
Does it have to be an
official transcript?
So for people to submit
their transcript,
is it OK if they just take a
screenshot of the transcript.
Yeah, unofficial.
Don't spend money.
Don't get it signed.
We can't read it.
There's digital [INAUDIBLE].
And we try to be flexible.
The objective is not to
make you go out of your way.
Is there a set
list of professors
that can be SuperUROP
supervisors,
or can you get any, as long
as you establish contact
with them?
So their department has to
be part of the participating
department.
For example,
mechanical engineering
is a participating
department, so you
can get a professor there.
I know there might be
some department x--
I know biology, probably, is
not a participating department.
And you can't just have
somebody in biology.
If you have somebody
in biology, then we
ask that you have someone
as kind of like a shadow
advisor in EECS.
But you're in 67--
yeah.
they can definitely [INAUDIBLE].
And you guys can send emails.
If you have specific questions
that are not answered,
or you have a specific
case, please send email
to this account.
Highly likely to
get in the class,
and then the next
question is whether we
have money to support it.
So that's a little bit
more challenging question.
What is the difference
between [INAUDIBLE] students
getting the advice [INAUDIBLE].
Getting into the class means
you can go to the class
and do your research for credit.
You know, EECS works
hard to raise money
to support SuperUROP
students, and we
don't know how many
we're going to have,
and we don't know whether the
sponsors are going to show up.
We're optimistic.
So basically, the department
raises money every year
to pay the students.
So we don't know ahead
of time how much money
we will be able to
raise, and therefore,
how many students, in total, we
are we can accept for funding.
You know, EECS students
working with EECS
professors, that's highly
likely to get funded.
EECS students working with
AeroAstro or MechE professors,
that's--
we funded them last year,
but we have enough money.
You're better off just working
with AeroAstro professors,
even like--
Well, it depends
whether AeroAstro
can find any [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe we can take it--
I'm just worried about, like,
there are two more speakers.
I can come to the end of the
class and answer your question
or Dorothy can
answer your question,
but I want to allow the other
two speakers enough time.
Should I go next?
Either one of you guys.
If I slide down this?
The slides?
Good afternoon, everyone.
So the Quest for Intelligence
is an MIT-wide initiative
on the science, engineering,
and application of intelligence.
And this year, we are
very happy to offer over
20 SuperUROP
possibilities of funding.
And so I'm one of the
directors of the Quest,
and I'm going to give you a
brief overview of the topics.
But most of the opportunities
related to the Quest
are not yet on the website.
We hope to have posted all of
them next week on the website,
so you have kind of
a preview right now.
So the projects come in
certain different types
of organization.
There is what we call
the bridge project.
So the Quest Bridge
is a community
of research scientists
and software engineers
who we are working with
undergraduate and graduate
students to [INAUDIBLE]
very big and large project.
And you have a few
titles over here.
If you're interested to work
with our students on a topic
that is highlighted here,
from gaze tracking
in childhood, or
greenhouse gas impact--
very important--
face recognition,
anything related to a
biology, like some topics,
then this might be something
that is good for you.
So we have a few on this.
There is a second type
of SuperUROP opportunity
that's actually more tied to
brain and cognitive science
development, and we call
them the Quest Science.
And they have a nickname--
Scaling AI the Human Way.
And this is an ambitious
research program that is lead
by Professor Josh Tenenbaum
and many of the faculty at MIT
CSAIL, and it's--
how can we build and grow
a system that will have some
intelligence resembling human
and child?
So there will be a few
projects, also, on that topic.
A further class of project, they
are on computational science
and engineering project--
those will be faculty driven.
So when you go next
week to the website
and you see some projects
you're interested in,
if you see Quest
written somewhere--
Quest for Intelligence-- it will
be one of those funded by us.
And here, you have three examples
that are on various topics.
And we also have a
project that are like--
we don't put an ad about
it, but I tell you about it.
Those will be any
faculty or project
you will propose to a
faculty related to fintech.
Then, we could pick it
up, if it's a project that
is interesting in that area.
So this is sort of this--
either you interested in this
larger topic, the finance
industry, and many
of the machine
learning algorithms that
are related to this, then
you can find the faculty
and come back to us saying,
hey, I found a faculty,
I have a good idea,
can we do something together?
So those are more open.
And we also have some that are
related to the MIT-IBM Watson
AI lab.
I'm also the director of this
lab on a variety of topic.
You will see the variety
of topic next week.
And what I would like to
emphasize today is certainly--
for the bridge project, the
computational engineering one,
some of the fintech,
and the MIT-IBM--
if you are interested
to go to industry,
then those are, potentially,
sorts of project
where you will do research
at MIT with an MIT professor,
but more aligned to some
of the questions that are
interesting in the industry.
So therefore,
beyond grad school,
those could offer
you the possibility
to have also somebody from
IBM close-up advising you,
but also start touching
some of the questions
interesting for industry.
Again, most of them will
be online next week.
Thank you.
Is there a question
I should take?
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, so I'm Mattie Wasiak
and I was a SuperUROP
student last year.
And so first off, does
anyone have any questions
about my experience personally?
Because I also have
talking points,
but if there are any
specific questions.
How did you find a SuperUROP?
I don't know if you did UROPs
in the past, but if you did,
did you see a difference
taking this SuperUROP?
Or just difference between
UROPing during your classes
and during SuperUROP.
Yes.
So I, to find my
project, there's
a list of SuperUROP projects.
And so I just went on that site
and looked through the projects
and found some that
I was interested in,
and then reached out to the
supervisors and met with them,
and then just saw what
would be a good match
and went with that.
And then, in terms of your
second question with the UROP,
I think SuperUROP was a lot more
structured and focused, kind
of like how Dina talked about.
You have deliverables
throughout the year
that you're actually working on.
And so, towards that
end, you have a paper
written and also a poster.
And so you're
guaranteed to have that.
And then also, I guess
I had weekly meetings
with my supervisor,
and so that really
helped keep the research going.
And then also, having
10 hours a week set
was a good way to make sure
that we were constantly working.
Because I know with your UROPs,
it's not as much pressure,
and it would sometimes sink
lower on my priority list.
But with SuperUROPs,
since there's
a class associated
with it and everything,
it was higher on
my priority list.
Class work involved?
What?
What's the coursework
involved with the class?
So the main stuff is the
paper, and then there's
also the poster.
But then, instead of--
they kind of split it up over
the course of the semester.
So I think you have to write
an introduction for one week,
and then you move
into methods, and then
related work and results.
And so it's split up
like week by week.
So I think they do a really
good job of helping you manage
your time, so it's
not like a scramble
at the end of the semester
to put it all together.
So in looking for a
project, do you just
find one on the
SuperUROP website
and reach out to that professor?
Or are you reaching
out with the intent of,
like, I read about your
project, and here's this thing I
want to extend on, I guess.
Yeah, so for me, it was
they had a proposed project,
and then I just talked
to them about it
and learned more about it, and
really was interested in it.
And so I just went with that.
I know you can also continue
extending a current UROP.
I think you can also
reach out to professors
and just learn more
about their research
and see if you want
to extend it, too.
So there's a bunch
of different options.
Yes.
There's posted projects, but you
do your SuperUROP with anyone,
and not every professor
posts projects.
So you should go with
professors you've
done well with in their class.
Any other questions?
So I guess I can just
talk a little bit more
about my experience.
So the reason that I
wanted to go into SuperUROP
was because I was planning
to do an  MEng
and I thought that it would
be more structured and more
long-term than just
a semester long UROP.
And so the main reason was to
prepare for the MEng
and then I also wanted
like the mentorship
in the lab and
also the classroom,
to improve the research
and communication skills.
And so my project was working
with Professor Thomas Heldt,
and then I worked with a
doctor at Beth Israel Medical
Center named Wendy Timpson.
And so my project was on
leveraging clinical data
to optimize oxygen
delivery to preterm
infants in the neonatal
intensive care unit.
And so we were just
analyzing different factors
that may be affecting the
oxygenation of preterm infants
and then trying to figure
out if we can improve
the clinical workflow to
maximize the amount of time
patients spend in their
target oxygen range
to prevent mortality
and morbidity.
And so, as I
mentioned before, it's
a really guided
research experience.
I thought the weekly
meetings with the professor
and the clinician
was really helpful.
And so, if you
guys do SuperUROP,
I would recommend like setting
that up because it really keeps
the research moving along.
I also got a bunch of
great opportunities,
such as shadowing the
neonatologist and a nurse
at the hospital and
just learning more
about the hospital workflow.
And then there were
weekly lab meetings
where we would learn about other
researchers in the lab and what
research they were doing.
And then I also got
to present at that,
so I got feedback on my
work and different ideas
that I could incorporate.
I also got to present at the
New England Perinatal Society
meeting, which is like a mini
conference for neonatologist
and clinicians in
the New England area.
And so that was a
really good experience
and definitely helped with
presentation practice.
And just overall, it was really
great to work on the project
and really dive deep into it
over the course of the year.
On the classroom
side of things, I
thought 6.UAR was really
interesting and useful.
The weekly lectures
with the researchers
presenting their work--
it was really cool to see like
different domains across campus
and just stay up to
date on research at MIT.
And then there were also TAs
and communication instructors
that would provide helpful
feedback for the research
paper and also the poster.
You should tell them
about any downsides.
I don't know if there
were any downsides.
I know some people have said
that some of the assignments
might be like busy work.
But personally, I thought that
everything was really useful
and really helped guide
writing the paper.
So yeah, I don't
know about downsides.
If there were any, I wanted to
you to save them beforehand.
Yeah, off the top
of my head, I can't
think of anything
negative about SuperUROP.
This might not be for you,
just for anyone else to answer.
Is there ever a time--
because you're doing research,
sometimes research work out,
right?
What happens then, if
you're trying something,
and it's not working,
and it's not working.
So you have all these meetings
every week with people,
and everybody will
agree what's happening.
Hopefully, they will have some
other ideas about other paths
to pursue.
Some people change
projects between the fall
and the spring, but
that's pretty tricky,
because you have to do
kind of all fall work.
And with a paper, you can
have negative results.
You can write up
everything you tried.
I mean, that that's really
useful to other people working
in the field, to
know what you tried.
Yeah.
Personally, I didn't have
any major road blocks.
But I know that some
people do, and I
think of you just communicate
with your supervisor,
it'll all work out in the end.
Yeah.
I guess, now that I'm thinking
about it, one kind of downside
was in the fall, I think,
since you're ramping up
your research, within
the first two weeks,
there's already things
due-- like an introduction.
And so it's totally OK to
not have your methods totally
fleshed out yet.
And just like having a starting
introduction and methods
is always good.
And so you don't need to
freak out and be like,
I haven't started
my research yet.
Like, what am I
supposed to be writing?
It's only two weeks in.
If you run into
trouble, you can also
go your TA and the
SuperUROP staff
and just let us know
and we can continue
to talk to the professor to
see if there's a way forward.
We're all there to try to
provide some safety net.
Yeah, that was another thing,
Is there's TAs and communication
instructors that you
work with, and so there's
check-ins with that,
and they really
help with the writing
process and also
putting together the poster.
And so I thought those
meetings were really helpful.
Yeah, and so overall, I think
it was a really good experience,
and I highly recommend doing it.
It's really cool to just work
on your research over the course
of a whole year, and then
have the deliverables,
like the poster and
the paper, at the end
to showcase everything
that you did.
And at the poster
presentations, you also
get to talk to other
people in your field,
and they can be interested
in your research
and then also tell you
what they've worked on.
And it's just a really
interesting experience.
So yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So thanks for coming.
There's fliers with
dates in the back.
There's a brochure in the back.
There's more pizza.
Let us know if you
have any questions.